welcome to this video playing Keys re
from Estonia s right yeah it is right
okay Queens gambit a new opponent never
played on the other Bishop f4 line
nowadays the main line of the Queens
gambit declined okay it's not going for
one of the more modern approaches with
night age 5 or 94 he plays it actually
like like I played this with black when
I was still playing this opening
regularly Bishop a six now I think it's
the unearned cards match yeah cards
Nylund yeah b5 is what what is that
that's the critical move but it's not I
totally know I don't really know any
details I know that this is right and
now they go here
that's all I know I think b4 night be
five and then a four is how it is played
think a form
yeah a form do you take this I don't
know take it I camp taking it allows
should shut closed the door check okay
yeah he's got siru k 5 is coming look if
I have probably it is wrong to take and
queen a six they are before playing such
a concrete line probably better to know
something about it oh really a three
that looks kind of weird really for Luke
see one and so on isn't that nice for
wine well thinking okay five is a bit
bit of a problematic news no look see
one threatening Bishop d6 I mean
sometimes I also just might take a three
so Bishop d6 you will play he will play
rugby five hmm if I gunite d6 takes
Bishop takes yeah and he's got queen
asics check that sets that's kind of
need and important
huh krea 6 a very annoying move
yeah anyway 96 it's a pretty forcing
business let's see 8 is a big thread
check and so I'll come on someone took
them so i can take your first right c8
takes TX bishop f8 yeah okay come on
let's let's go there
Jack okay some to hear ya i'm going to
be in an exchange of endgame just the
question is what kind of endgame how
good is it 95 95 or not me it looks it
looks like the right moves
of course I can always take on f8
playbook a two and take on Roxy to take
on a two but maybe I can can do more
using the activity that that I have yes
so I DM is king g7 yeah I can play
something like rook c7 try to just take
on f7 or take the odd or get the pawn
yeah it's both possible I come on let's
get the poem it's from a technical point
of view a very very nice position
probably winning
now let's see how to do that is king is
cut off I can give this chick first you
for it's good gaining space-time morning
point excess 97 96 Jack also didn't help
much than rugby 7s coming
my name playing for me playing for meit
is often a good idea black Rosaiah okay
just seven mate yeah I don't I read oh
no this is another hugely theoretical
duel and I really don't know don't know
what's going on here I was thinking yeah
now that's not what they do right the
comp actually suggests rook c1 and that
is probably the right move now I did not
remember how this some 9,000 came was
was played it was this island cars name
was the only one that I didn't really
watch at all the wind that are non
scored early on because I was a very
sick at the time had a stomach bug and I
couldn't really do anything i was just
lying in bed and no idea what happened
in this game so but this is probably
wrong this looks kind of wrong a 3 was
surprising i was thinking that this is a
somewhat strange move okay if I it was
what I expected attacking he and
intending Queen a 6 ok now I lost the
thread completely him I got a phone call
that had to take yeah this I think was
was better I ok five he went here though
and this gives me be free which is
certainly useful yeah okay yeah I can
also just take a three but I thought
Luke see one looks very normal yeah 496
or bishop t6 ok five and now I went here
so check yeah I gave the check here
a compounds through this which is Jack
which is comparable rook c8 this is what
I was thinking this kind of continuation
there thought I should be okay about he
has an ID eight okay yeah something
something like that hey I probably have
enough compensation here at least
something like this is it's a regaining
material and that's equal half may be
equal check this is what he did and now
I can I can promote for us and finding
him yeah here book c7 was attempting
move probably not bad but I thought that
it's just simpler to to get this
computer agrees actually yeah yeah I'm
pretty easily winning because the be
porn is not very threatening I'm very
close with the king and it's not really
yeah even advancing and the 95 rook on
the 7th is just wrong now that's a
fairly fairly easy when he cannot
activate his pieces and in any
meaningful way okay thanks for watching